okay here we go it's a 15-minute game oh
i just i intended to five but ok now we
got a 15 minute game alright um let's
see what opening we got here matura
attack yeah black of course not multiple
ways to play this
can we go for a c5 and b6 set up to play
d5 just just like in the Queens gambit
but if other options also try some other
setup that I think it's interesting the
idea is to to play a g5 and night h5
grapping the bishop and d6 was play to
get rid of Bishop b5 ideas case playing
a 4 ok not sure if this is the correct
set up here with the form because it has
a tendency to to weaken the dark squares
a bit not not terribly or something but
I was more expecting III you three set
up ok the question is should i take or
does it have some married to two
somewhat delayed this not sure ok on the
night most likely goes to c6 in this
kind of position but i'm not sure if he
may be a Scott Bishop b5 496 looks
somewhat annoying
and I'm also not quite sure what to send
information like after right after I
take not sure want to play you five
because it would we can f5 a lot and I
don't want to move the pawns there at
all really at least them at first
ok maybe ppl 96 ok I wasn't really
planning d5 so a 4 i'm not sure cause I
can play this is done does it hurt this
position a lot or not it already ok I
think it's time to capture now No ok
let's get this out I'm curious does he
castle now or does he delay it could be
interesting to to delay castle in here
yeah but ok nan cancel our team split a
form that seam doesn't somewhat unlikely
if 535 is interesting
yeah after he's played if I've i would
like to cancel long but of course with a
6 plate not so sure this is really a
good idea I go d5 I would take the CYT
foursquare which is nice but it also
would block both my bishop somehow
normal will be just capture here what if
I just if I capture you capture to the
point of a g4 immediately then I should
be able to grab it five so most likely
you would need to take with with the
night here and of course this is a good
exchange for me okay
yeah II fibers of course the main main
issue here he 535 yeah I might play a
for later to protect this
you have a problem here is that I'm not
quite sure what I will do my with my
king it's not so bad on the eight but I
need to create rooks I think I just go
Bishop c6 first of course he could go be
should be for now to get rid of my
bishop pair but I didn't see a better
move really was intending Quincy five
now yeah 25 d5 threatened slightly it
would need to take now and then Quincy 6
which should um windows small tempo in
g2 and maybe then I can Cass along with
the white squared bishops off he doesn't
have to standard sacrifice on a six and
still alive might be might be a weak
spot here check ok maybe you can still
just play a form it's possible we cancel
short interesting
can I go lot longer so now and before
then I can capture c3 yeah what what
what else should i do i need to be
together looks into play okay I've also
h5 h4 maybe
ok so we're protecting e5 cannot take on
e5 greenie 552 because h8 is hanging the
question is should i go h 5 h 4
yeah come on because I also could have
maybe I should have invested a bit more
time Group D 5 might have been
interesting
yeah it would have been an interesting
IDM okay um so what now I could I could
also just play mg4 here but it's got
Knight to g5 also h4 also possible yeah
I would open up the g4 was slightly not
not too bad
ok
huh
and g4 was much more solid on Bishop h6
he can take on g5 I think who didn't
take this too seriously but maybe he can
do this take on g3 just take on f7 not
sure that I really have something man
I'm I could take and play ruka fate and
then the slightest in a somewhat nasty
pin yeah okay come on
you
yeah this looks really really really
shaky okay let's say Quincy five if he
goes queen III I can exchange and play
Bishop h6 and then this night has also
pinning problem here on Queen f2 I can
play rook h1 sorry it doesn't have any
other move where something better even
now check among this enough
yeah King everyone rook h1 mate Queen f2
Luke edge one wins the Queen on Queen
III I can captured Bishop h6 and it's
over okay over I've got an extra piece
extra piece then that he's got this huge
problems with this sorry with this king
also
yeah thinking I think he needed 2 1 f'd
XD so you need to take on f7 okay on f7
I can I can also play just drew cafe
diem I'm really slow technically here to
take I can can show this briefly
afterwards if you would have taken on f7
I could could play look a fade and this
should be good for me so night x g5
maybe was bad after all okay as I'm
really a super slow in calculating
obviously today I'm not too sure that
this is a correct assessment I checked
this afterwards yeah said but she needs
to do this yeah you can he can get f7
most gladly quite resigned oh that was a
quick resign yeah it certainly am
certainly a correct decision I need to
chai want to check quickly here h4 yeah
this is already clearly better for black
so but I just like just calculated
complete nonsense here what I what I
meant to show us that if it takes on f7
now I can just play rook to f8 rook d to
f 8 and then you cannot take h eight
because f 2 is hanging gtex have to
check and wins lots of material so he
doesn't really have a movie m this is
already already lost position will
combine the techie ref to rook d 55 and
the loose night is just too much a
compass on minus one point six year
already
so yeah so cannot he cannot take it
needs to take on h form and okay then I
just I just recap show on g4 I play h3 I
think with interesting play comcast g4
with the clear advantage to white
interesting 83 is not good yeah I'm not
sure anyway here I also had the simple
alternative or playing G form which is
actually I'm from a strategic point of
view the the cleaner solution because it
it drives the night to to another post
where it doesn't cover a five so g4
would be the the principal moved to
increase the pressure on e5 so maybe
this this was better but okay I to
decide with little time yeah thanks for
watching